millions of people across China are
mourning former Premier lean State media
say he died from a heart attack just
months after stepping down from his
position as the country's second highest
ranked official Lee was elected Premier
in 2012 tasked with executing government
policy and overseeing the economy he
championed Market reforms and in 2020
sparked debate on Rising poverty and
inequality niik has devoted his whole
life to the modernization and
industrialization and the social
progress for the Chinese people though
Lee advocated for a Freer economy and
supply side reform some analysts say he
was sidelined by President Cen Ping's
tightening grip on power even so State
media described the former Premier as a
tough wall breaker in 2014 when Beijing
was blanketed in a hazardous smog he
declared war on pollution challenging
the government's prioritization of
growth over the environment the level of
smoke is growing the problem of
environmental pollution is more
obvious a fluent English speaker Lee was
considered one of beijing's most
educated officials he studied law and
economics at peing University one of
China's most prestigious tery
institutions he was frequently seen on
the ground during disasters and had the
challenge of steering the world's second
largest economy through the co 19
pandemic Leo Chang will be remember as
the people's Premier one who died too
early and whose career was overshadowed
by The Growing Power of his boss Katrina
U aler
Beijing make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from
aler